okay I would like to introduce all of
you beautiful curious minded people to
my favorite animal in the world this is
the Peter Pan of the amphibian world
it's an axolotl so it's a type of
salamander but it never fully grows up
and climbs out of the water like other
salamanders do and this little guy has
x-men style powers right so if it loses
any limb it can just completely
regenerate it's amazing and I mean look
at it it's got a face with a permanent
smile it's framed by feathery gills it's
just how could you not love that this
particular type of axolotl a very close
relative is known as a nacho Kay it is
equally as cute and and it lives in just
one place in a lake in the north of
Mexico
it's called Lake patzcuaro and and as
you can see it is stunningly beautiful
but unfortunately it's been so over
fished and so badly polluted that hok is
dying out altogether and this is
something that's a scenario that's
playing out all over the world we're
living through an extinction crisis and
species are particularly vulnerable when
they're evolutionarily tailored to just
one little niche or maybe one lake but
this is Ted right so this is where I
give you the big idea the big solution
so how do you save one special weird
species from going extinct well the
answer at least my answer isn't a grand
technological intervention it's actually
really simple it's that you find people
who know all about this animal and you
ask them and you listen to them and you
work with them if they're up for that so
I want to tell you about how I've seen
that in science and in conservation in
particular if scientists don't team up
with local people who have really
valuable knowledge but a practical
wisdom that's not going to be published
in any academic journal they can really
miss the point scientists and science as
an enterprise can fall at the first
hurdle if it rushes in knowing that it
the experts that know best but when
scientists shake off those academic
constraints and really look to people
who have a totally different but really
important perspective on what they're
trying to do it can genuinely save the
world
one wonderfully weird amphibian at a
time so in the case of the otoki these
are the people you need on your team
these are the sisters of the immaculate
health they are nuns who have a convent
in patzcuaro they live in patzcuaro and
they have a shared history with the
otoki and it is so mind bogglingly
wonderful that it drew me all the way
there to make an audio documentary about
them and I even have the unflattering
selfie to prove it so there is a room at
the center of their convent though that
looks like this it's very strange it's
lined with all these tanks full of fresh
water and hundreds of a chokers and
that's because this creature because if
it's of its regenerative abilities it's
believed has healing powers if you
consume it so the sisters actually make
and sell a medicine using a choke ace I
bought a bottle of it so it's this is it
it tastes a bit like honey um but the
sisters reckon it is good for all kinds
of particularly respiratory ailments so
I just want you to have a listen if you
will to a clip of sister or philia
convent was founded by Dominican nuns
here in patzcuaro in 1747 some time
after that our sisters started to make
the hok syrup we didn't discover the
properties of the hok that was the
original people from around here since
ancient times but we then started to
make the syrup too
the locals knew that and they came to
offer us the animals I see
so theater keys are part of making that
syrup what is this syrup treats what is
it for years one of us but I let dolls
bronchospasm it's good for coughs asthma
bronchitis the lungs and back pain and
so you've harnessed that power in a
syrup and in a medicine can you tell me
how it's made
you're shaking your head and smiling
yeah they're not sure in the
centuries-old secret recipe but and this
this seed you choke a the decline in the
otoko actually nearly put a halt to that
medicine production altogether which is
why the sisters started this is the
world's first hok farm so all they
wanted was a healthy sustainable
population so that they could continue
to make that medicine but what they
created at the same time was a captive
breeding program for a critically
endangered species and fast-forward a
few years and these scientists that you
can see in this picture from Chester Zoo
although all the way over in the UK not
far from where I live and for a Mitchell
Carney University in Morelia in Mexico
have persuaded the sisters took years of
careful diplomacy to join them in a
research partnership so the nuns show
the biologists how urea perfectly
healthy very robust patzcuaro Ocho Ches
and the scientists have put some of
their funding into tax filters and pumps
in this strange incongruous but amazing
room this is the kind of partnership
that can save a species but I don't
think I see enough of this sort of thing
and I have been ludicrously lucky in my
job I've traveled to loads of places and
just basically followed around brilliant
people who are trying to use science to
answer big questions and solve problems
so I've hung out with scientists who've
solved the mystery of the origin of the
menopause by tracking killer whales of
the North Pacific coast and I've
followed around scientists who've
planted cameras in Antarctic penguin
colonies because they were looking to
capture the impacts of climate change as
it happens but it's this team that
really stuck with me that really showed
me the impact that these delicate but
really important relationships can have
and I think the reason that it stuck
with me as well is because it's not
common and one of the reasons it's not
common is because our traditional
approach of the hierarchical system of
academic achievement doesn't exactly
encourage the type of humility where
scientists will look to non-scientists
and really ask for their input in
I think we have a bit of a tradition
especially in the west of a kind of
academically blinkered hubris that has
kept science historically an enterprise
for the elite and I think although
that's moved on it continues to be its
downfall on occasion so here's my
example from history and my takedown of
a scientific hero so Ernest Shackleton
and his Transantarctic expedition more
than a century ago the celebrated
ill-fated adventurer on his way there
Shackleton just didn't listen to the
Whalers in South Georgia
they knew that region and they told him
you won't get through the ice this year
it's too widespread it's too far north
it's too dangerous I knew what happened
I mean granted that great adventure that
story of heroic leadership that we still
tell where he saved every single one of
his men
we wouldn't be telling that story if he
just hightailed it for home and taking
their advice but it cost him his ship I
would imagine quite a lot of cold
injuries among the team a good few cases
of PTSD and mrs. chitthi the ship's cat
had to be shot because the team couldn't
afford any extra food as they fought to
survive now that was all a very long
time ago but as I've prepared for this
talk I've revisited some of the stories
that I have covered we're these really
unusual collaborations made a real
positive difference so I spoke to former
poachers whose knowledge of where they
used to hunt illegally is now really
important in conservation projects in
those same places and I spoke to an
amazing artist whose own experience of
mental health struggles has actually
paved the way for him to take a role in
designing and creating a new really
innovative and beautiful mental health
ward in a hospital most recently I
worked here in the Chernobyl exclusion
zone with a team of scientists that have
been working there for decades one of
their experiments growing crops in that
area has now turned into this
it's Chernobyl's first vodka
it's pretty good too I've tasted it um
and this is actually although it looks
like a niche product it's actually it's
gonna be it or it's set to be the first
consumer product to come out of the
exclusion zone since the nuclear
accidents and that's actually the result
of years of conversation with local
communities who still live on the
periphery of that abandoned land and
want to know when they can and if they
can safely grow food and build
businesses and rebuild their communities
in their lives this was a product of
humility of listening and I saw that in
spades when I visited Pat's grow so I
watched as a decade's experience
conservation biologist called Gerardo
Garcia listened and watched super
carefully as a nun in a full habit and
wimple and latex gloves showed him how
have you tapping a choker on the head
really gently it'll open its mouth so
you can quickly get a DNA swab with a
q-tip when scientists team up with look
to and defer to people who have a really
valuable perspective on what they're
trying to do but a totally different
outlook something really special can
happen now there is a truly global and a
very very ambitious example of this
called the International Panel on
biodiversity and ecosystem services now
that is not a snappy title but stick
with me this organization includes more
than 130 countries and it's aiming to do
nothing less than assess the state of
the natural world across our entire
planet so it recently published this
global assessment on the state of nature
and that could be the foundation for an
international agreement where all of
those nations could sign up to finally
take action to tackle the biodiversity
crisis that's happening on planet earth
right now now I know from trying to
communicate trying to report on reports
like this on assessments like this for a
broad audience that these big
international groups can seem so
high-level as to be kind of out of reach
and nebulous but there's a group of
human beings at the center of them the
report's authors who have this
formidable task of bringing together all
of that biological and ecological
information that paints a clear and
accurate picture of the states of the
natural world and ten years before this
panel even
set out to do that to put that
assessment together they created what's
called a cultural concept framework so
this is essentially a cultural concept
translation dictionary right for all of
the different ways that we talk about
the natural world so it formally
recognizes for example that mother earth
and nature means the same thing and what
that means is that indigenous and local
knowledge can be brought into the same
document and given the weight and merit
that it deserves in that assessment of
what our natural environment what states
our natural environment is in and that
is absolutely critical because you know
an Inuit hunter might never publish in
an academic journal but I'll bet you she
knows more about the changes to her home
Arctic community because of climate
change than a scientist who spent many
years going to and from that region
taking measurements and collectively
indigenous people are the caretakers of
an estimated 25 percent of the entire
global run surface including some of the
most biodiverse places on the planet so
imagine how much we're missing if we
don't cross those cultural boundaries or
at least try to when we're trying to
figure out how the world works and how
to protect it every single research
proposal is a new opportunity to do
exactly that so what if every time a
research project was proposed it had to
include a suggestion of a person or a
group of people local farmers indigenous
community leaders nuns the researchers
wanted to bring into the fold inviting
to their team and listen to I just want
to let sister Ophelia give her view of
why she's so particularly driven and
dedicated to the survival of the otoko
sister feel you do you think that saving
this species from extinction is that
part of your work for God when it's no
responsibility that at all certain
mandibles god it's the responsibility of
every human being not to harm those who
live around us that's all living things
we're all created not only just to
survive
but to be happy and to make others happy
all of us here are providing happiness
by protecting this animal and we're also
making him fairly see that
[Music]
I feel like I should slink off and let
the nuns sing me out because it sounds
it sounds so lovely but did he hear that
we're providing happiness now that's not
a protocol you'd ever see outlined in
any formal research project proposal but
it's the impetus behind what's become
the most successful breeding program in
the world of an animal that was on the
very brink of being wiped out and isn't
that just wonderful
thank you
[Applause]